a verdict announced in the derrick
chauvin murder trial we're continuing
our coverage for you right now i'm
christian casadas and i'm kirsten joyce
we are checking in with the itunes
vanessa murphy
she spoke with one of nevada's most
well-known criminal defense attorneys
about the verdict
the charges and much more she joins us
live in studio
thank you for joining us vanessa well it
is rare for a jury to convict a police
officer
in america criminal defense attorney
david chesnov points to a strategy
used by the prosecution here to tell the
jury this wasn't
prosecution against police it was
prosecution against a man who happened
to be a police officer again usually
jurors
are sympathetic to law enforcement but
this jury came back with a verdict of
guilty on all three counts
chesnov says he believes both the
prosecution
and defense did a good job in this case
and he tells me he believes there's not
much
derek chovin's defense attorney could do
especially because of the video of
chauvin kneeling on george floyd's neck
i mean i i've thought of different
defenses maybe
some maybe some kind of a mental illness
defense because
to have somebody standing there in the
face of people
telling him that the person is dying and
not to do anything it's just
there was something either very sadistic
about this guy
i mean it was like a lynching
jurors deliberated for about 10 hours
before delivering the verdict